[Music]
Chucky's show with how Rudnick its
Django day why because we feel like it
toy company NECA
has come out with a line of Django
Unchained action figures oh man what a
party Al Sharpton is telling you to
boycott these figures but you're not
going cutting these figures they're sold
out everywhere no one could get their
hands on one of these things except us
reach for the sky you mother is this too
offensive we decided to go to South
Central Los Angeles and talk to the
people to find out gender
what were your thoughts about Django I
really enjoyed it it was a good
entertainment but I didn't see no
offensive though what do you think about
Django I say give us our reparations and
I love Jamie Foxx what'd you think about
the length of the movie too long that's
why I fell asleep
we snore it in the movie there I was
told I did snore a couple times in them
Oh met Roger have you seen any other
Quentin Tarantino movies like Kill Bill
what about inglorious bastard I fell
asleep on it I'm a little bit offended
cuz I'm a Jew and that was about you
know saving Jews and like stopping
Hitler sorry bro I went to McDonald's
and LaBrea
and Rodion there's no blacks working
there who is working there Hispanics I'm
not as prejudiced I'm not racist you're
not prejudiced and you're not racist but
you sound a little racist and president
what do you think about this is this an
appropriate thing to make a Django
action figure actually is really neat I
would actually buy it myself I wouldn't
buy because I mean it was just a movie
I mean I'm gonna go buy all honest was a
[ __ ] action figure you know me neither
nowadays well what do you think about
this Django action figure oh no you
can't have it you can't have it okay
take a picture do you think it will hurt
my chances with women if they know I
play with dolls yes
don't jacket I think making an action
figure can be viewed as inappropriate
but when I look at the action figure I
just see capitalism at work all right
you can let go now are there any movies
or TV shows that you think it would be
inappropriate to make action figures for
Family Guy I love Family Guy but that's
a one you're the second person down here
today that said Family Guy's look too
offensive to make activate and they
already got them they do you ever heard
a big bang theory you think a Big Bang
Theory action figure be more offensive
than a Django action figure correct
you heard it here big bang more
offensive than Django in the black
community
what about Django breakfast cereal
should be good yeah I think maybe be
called Django O's good name what if they
made a Django breakfast cereal
that's inappropriate but what if it was
totally delicious maybe maybe it comes
with a free whip at the bottom of the
box the person easily with whoever think
about it
are you saying I need to be whipped for
even mentioned I'm with you now man
maybe I'd like it though let me ask you
a question you ever get your Django's
frosted sometime what if there was a
Universal Studios Django Unchained the
ride I wouldn't go on I think maybe that
might that might be taking a little too
far what would you put in there Kerry
Washington
what about Django the musical that is
different let me ask you this do you
want to kill a white guy and get paid
sure and together were bounty hunter
that's nonsense
I mean this might be too far but
somebody wanted I guess they want it you
know by AlterNet it was just a movie and
it's just a dog that's it it's just a
movie it's just a dog well I think we've
confirmed one thing for certain black
people love how Rudnick this video
really got me thinking what movies would
be too offensive to have action figures
up Human Centipede the Mount fits right
to the bun sweep the accused with mini
pinball machine oh that's terrible guys
Love Guru
that's even worse guys tell us what
movie action figure would be the most
offensive to you best answer gets a
screen junkies t-shirt that thing I'm al
Rudnick bye bye
[Music]